[Music]
heading to parliament to face a chorus
of complaints over sleaze
back discussing standards the mood
souring the prime minister and his
government have been up to their next in
threes
weeks defending corruption
yesterday a screeching last-minute
u-turn it's been ill-tempered i think it
shows the public
that this house has not learned from the
other week today mps entered a third
week discussing their own behaviour what
started as allegations against one tory
mp for breaking lobbying rules has
spiraled now it is about boris johnson's
judgment and how everything has to
change the labour leader wanted an
apology will he do the decent thing
and just say sorry for trying to give
the green light to corruption
it certainly was a mistake uh to
conflate the case of an into an
individual member
no matter how sad with the point of
principle at stake that's not an apology
everybody else everybody else has
apologized for him but he won't
apologize for himself a coward not a
leader
uncomfortable questions about the prime
minister's ethical judgments now follow
him wherever he goes an afternoon of
cross-parliamentary grilling on the very
same issue the pm on the edge of his
seat do you believe that owen patterson
broke the rules yes yes or no yes and
and
uh
at least that's seems to me too
yes i do you are still qualifying it
you're still saying well it seems to me
can you clarify you don't think it's
okay
patterson did was wrong
did i that was the first thing i said
when i when i uh when i
began on this subject two weeks ago
tonight came a vote on whether or not
there should be new restrictions on
second jobs the eyes to the right 297
the nose to the left zero that means mps
have agreed to reforms in principle but
it's not clear what comes next or if
anything will ultimately change
boris johnson has been confronted by
questions of ethics and standards before
and has always managed just to brush
them off what's fascinating about what's
going on at the moment is just how
unimpressed his own side is with his
handling particularly new mps elected in
2019 boris johnson made another apology
behind closed doors tonight tory mps it
doesn't seem to have generated much
sympathy
this former chief whip making his
unhappiness clear i don't think the last
couple of weeks has been
particularly helpful for anybody frankly
not for the conservative party not for
parliament but what the prime minister
has done is bring full proposals from an
independent committee from the committee
on standards i think those are a sound
basis to improve things
mps billable hours standards debates
stretching over weeks none of it clasts
this place in a good light sam coates
sky news westminster